on a le bonheur d'avoir et la londe avec
nous qui est un expert du marketing du
sport vous avez été vice président
marketing du canadien les ventes
également de 2001 à 2011 françois ray
lalonde on songeait également avec nous
donald beauchamp donald beauchamp qui
est conseiller spécial chez tacca est
également vice président du ch aux
communications pendant 25 ans monsieur
brou chamond soir
alors un premier commentaire d'abord une
première réaction c'est un homme dans
une classe à part ray lalonde
quelques sentiments vous habitent
aujourd'hui une journée de tristesse
pour le québec et pour le canada moi je
considérais toujours guy lafleur comme
l'idole d'une nation y ont pris le
relais au moment où l'expansion de la
ligue nationale n'avait pas encore pris
place et avec eux les livres et les
canadiens puis les canucks se sont
joints dans 70 71 lafleur était le héros
d'une nation qui adorait les canadiens
de vancouver à terre-neuve parce que les
canadiens gagnait souvent et il était le
meilleur parmi donc maurice richard jean
béliveau dernier match jean béliveau il
prend sa retraite dans la coupe stanley
guy lafleur arrive la saison suivante et
c'est le début d'une séquence où il a
été le meilleur joueur de hockey au
monde et ça c'est pas peu dire jeu
savant l'arrivée de wayne gretzky alors
toutes les choses arrivent dans le bon
ordre et moi je trouve qu'aujourd'hui
c'est la nation qui est en deuil donald
beauchamp votre première émotion qui
vous habite aujourd'hui
bien du même âge que lui même avait deux
hommes étant je joins ma voix que tu
suis qui ont enfin dans sa place à la
famille de guy connu très bien sa femme
et ses deux garçons
par contre qu'ils sa carrière sa vie
aurait été en deux temps comme mentionné
pendant six années c'était le meilleur
joueur d'arsenal
avait par contre depuis sa retraite et
dans les 25 années où j'ai passé des
coups avait fait qu'un événement de la
farce est un être exceptionnel et puis
même aujourd'hui il est décédé à l'âge
de 70 ans mais en chantant les gens des
gens savent ce qui donc vraiment
c'est ce qui c'est ce que je trouve le
plus de plus impressionnant donc la
qualité de l'être humain et donc il est
auteur ray lalonde dans le fond guy
lafleur encore de l'existence du
canadien de la marque du canadien de
montréal aujourd'hui quarante ans après
sa retraite ou trente ans après sa
retraite il est encore parce que le
canadien c'est de faire c'est à dire
d'écrire une histoire d'attirer des
spectateurs de faire aimer cette équipe
là tu te fais péter un instigateur un
polar isr qui réussit à faire aimer le
ch partout au pays reconnaître le ch
dans le monde du hockey partout dans le
monde parce qu'on suivait les exploits
d'un joueur exceptionnel et comme donald
dit c'est un individu qui chaque fois
qu'il entre dans une salle chaque fois
qu'ils prenaient la parole chaque fois
qu'il rencontrait quelqu'un il laissait
une énorme influence une énorme beaucoup
d'inspiration ses rangs les individus
qui touche les gens de tellement de
façons différentes pendant de si longues
années dans l'ordre guy laplante comme
ça mais vous qui êtes inquiet des hommes
de marketing et de communication de la
lgv au chant ckoi l'importance d'un guy
lafleur pour faire fonctionner justement
une entreprise qui s'appelle le canadien
de montréal
le canadien de montréal présentement et
celle qui était la finale coupe stanley
puis que ses hauts et ses bords mais guy
lafleur élégant les gens prendraient se
chargeant belvaux on en avait
quelques-uns ce sont des gens qui qui
représente l'image lanark d'une grande
organisation et prend les ans des
yankees de new york que ce soit babe
ruth lou gehrig joe dimaggio mais qui
manteau on pense encore à ces gens là
mais jusqu'à hier ou plutôt ce matin
qu'il a faim et un légende vivante
aujourd'hui va rentrer dans une nouvelle
réalité c'est à dire qu' il va devenir
une légende jusque pour tous les uns et
ça pour une organisation pour l'anah
convoi le goût du canadien les joueurs
n'est pas si ça n'a pas de prix parce
que ça ne se quantifie pas
exactement parce que même le canadien en
ce moment ramène les anciens joueurs
lèvent encore doyon au lioran dommage
cette semaine c'est important cette
histoire là pour faire battre le coeur
d'aider des fans aujourd'hui en 2022 ben
je pense qu'on est souvent parfois en
train de ce questionnaire savoir comment
jusqu'à quel degré on va aller dans le
passé d'une franchise deux heures quand
on met en marche et une équipe
d'aujourd'hui pour le présent et
l'avenir mais quand une équipe si
glorieuse avec tellement de succès 24
coupes stanley en 112 qui la plus grande
de toutes les équipes sportives en
amérique avec les yankees de new york
c'est pas peu dire alors il ya tellement
de légende qui ont bâti sous le
privilège d'être dans une organisation
commune et canadien c'est des
témoins de ces gens l'aude au jour le
jour puis le centenaire nous a donné
l'occasion d'honorer leur histoire cet
élevage 2009la 2009 en 2009 j'étais là
tous les deux le centenaire c'était
essentiel d'avoir guy lafleur absolument
une pièce maîtresse parce que même si on
en aurait 200 300 quelques anciens
vivant à l'époque guy lafleur jean
béliveau demeurait les rois incontestés
de la marque des canadiens ceux qui
perpétuent est le message à chacun de
leur passage donald beauchamp est ce que
guy lafleur est arrivé
je dirais pas au mauvais moment parce
que il est de son époque tout simplement
des années soixante dix particulièrement
des années 70 une partie des années 80
mais on disait tantôt il a gagné à peu
près 200 1000 par année ce qui est
peut-être huit cent mille en ce moment
aujourd'hui se joue à arles donald
beauchamp et gagnerait guy lafleur 12 12
millions par année pas dans la même
catégorie que les corps mais des vitres
voilà un volet annexe exercée sur wii
jeu d'accord avec vous mais quand vous
l'avez mentionné ce serait important on
était allé pas que c'était ça le salaire
c'est un des meilleurs joueurs
d'ailleurs un des premiers joie qui qui
s'est soulevée qui fait la grève pour
avoir des salaires ça peut durer
longtemps je pense que j'ai même pas vu
le match ouais il s'était servi d'amendé
des médias et rapidement on ajuste son
salaire mais qui sont grandes et des
petites sommes sont pas à ce qu'il
devrait faire aujourd'hui et ces cas et
il a fait énormément ray lalonde de
publicité cet homme là on l'a vu dans
une automobile on l'a vu chez power on
l'a vu chez sherweb les entreprises
voulaient être associé à lui c'était le
porte-parole publicitaire le plus en vue
tu te fais parce que c'était le
personnage
québécois du sport le premier ministre
le goût en a parlé c'est un gagnant il
gagnait on voulait des gagnants nous
aussi donc on va s'associer à guy
lafleur mais je reviens un peu sur le
point sur les salaires guy lafleur
aujourd'hui serait le mieux payé werss
qu'il était le meilleur joueur à
l'époque bon alors aujourd'hui il n'est
pas le mieux payé quand il était le
meilleur joueur de l'epo non mais les
salaires de ce moment là n'avaient pas
atteint cette espèce de tournant de
sport marketing et de l'importance y
avait d'abord pas de médias sociaux il
demain ils répondront plus d'occasions
de voir ses gueules régulièrement la
télé il y avait un ou deux matches par
semaine seulement à la télé donc la
commercialisation des athlètes c'est
arrivé pas longtemps après d'ailleurs
michael jordan c'est un peu le premier
visage du sport marketing pitt arrive en
95 alors la flore terminer sa carrière
si lafleur avait joué aujourd'hui guy
lafleur serait excessivement populaire
dans le monde entier c'était donald
beauchamp un entrepreneur également un
guy lafleur s'est lancé en affaires à
plusieurs reprises
oui mais ce qui était ce qui est un
petit public avec de la fleur oui
c'était lancent en affaires surtout avec
les fusions des marques que vous avez
montré à l'écran et l'égalisation
également la restauration mais c'était
un peu on dirait que lille ne suivant
dans mon bureau le jour dans le match
disons que je vous donne un exemple et
une belle année guy avait un engagement
commercial dont le match du canadien au
centre bell pendant la semaine un soir
donné et son engagement commencé à 17
ans se présente au centre à 14 heures on
n est pas évident à s'asseoir dans le
bureau de jeff moss hull ou dans mon
bureau il pendant des heures ils
parlaient monza qui il n'était pas tout
à fait comme ancien de du pouvoir
d'attraction marketing qui l'avait est
en réalité je crois que c'est le repas
cochon d'esprit que c'est un ambassadeur
pour l'équipe et y laisser ça aux gens
son entourage est-ce que lui se sent
il s'est impliqué beaucoup socialement
l'engagement social très présent auprès
des jeunes faisait des cliniques de à
qui je tombais sur des vidéos
aujourd'hui il faisait des cliniques de
hacker s'est impliqué dans les anciens
du canadien la fondation du chum bien
sûr au cours des derniers mois mais
commençons par les anciens canadiens
quelque peu terni sa carrière il a joué
beaucoup de matches avec le groupe
d'anciens qui voyagez à travers le pays
faire encore une fois la promotion de la
marque des canadiens et de ses légendes
bleus tous ensemble qu'ils étaient tous
fiers de jouer avec guy lafleur encore
une fois même monnaie a arrêté de jouer
ces matches-là il sait focus et sur les
histoires les efforts communautaires et
c'est très impliqué les canadiens sont
bien structurés au niveau relations
communautaires puis ils ont toujours
bien utiliser grâce à réjean houle jean
béliveau yvan cournoyer henri richard et
guy lafleur qui étaient les quatre
grands ambassadeurs de l'équipe donc ils
avaient beaucoup d'influx ans mais
beaucoup d'importance dans la communauté
québécoise pour coup repoussé encore à
plus tard cet amour pour le club et
beaucoup beaucoup de témoignages
aujourd'hui beaucoup de gens se sont
prononcés ont se sont bien sûr exprimés
ont exprimé leur leurs amours leurs
peines leurs émotions en terminant
donald beauchamp si je vous demandais un
mot ou une image qui vous restent de guy
lafleur
une grande simplicité mais aujourd'hui
ce qui occupe mon esprit c'est drôle
parce que dans les entrevues qu'on ait
demandé de faire ce que lorsqu'on met
les pieds au centre bell aujourd'hui ben
il ya un restaurant qui s'appelle le 9 4
espoo maréchal jean béliveau guy lafleur
et guillet le troisième défi est décédée
et sept images de mares et ce qui me
reste sur un côté personnel humain c'est
sa très très grande simplicité
mais moi ce que j lorsqu'on a le
privilège de travailler dans une
organisation aussi
importante dans la société projette dans
le sport dans la société que les
canadiens côtoyer ces légendes là quand
je passe devant le centre bell puis je
vois la statue de guy lafleur
en bronze je sais qu'il est devenu un
immortel du rock et puis les gens ont
l'occasion à chaque jour d'aller voir et
toucher guy lafleur lire sur sa vie
comment il a impacté cette équipe là
alors il y en a seulement quatre statues
il ya une raison pour ça il fait partie
des quatre plus grands merci beaucoup
ray lalonde merci beaucoup donald
beauchamp avoir été avec nous ce soir
merci à vous deux pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit